the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
let's take a look at storyboard 14 where
I discuss the cue cycle if you look back
at my previous lecture in which I
introduced the respiratory apparatus
you'll see that there are three points
in the electron transport chain at which
protons are translocated across the
mitochondrial inner membrane into the
intermembrane space the three sites are
complex 1 complex 2 and complex 4 if
your entry point for the electrons is a
pair of electrons at NADH you'll
translocate about 10 protons this
generates the electrochemical gradient
that will be used in complex 5 the F
naught F 1 ATP synthase and the energy
released in proton translocation back
into the cytoplasm eventually will be
used to synthesize ATP at this point I'd
like to take a look at the hypothetical
mechanism by which proton translocation
into the intermembrane space happens in
complex 3 at the outset let me say that
the mechanism here is different from the
mechanism at complex 1 and complex 4 and
I'll also mention that other organisms
have found other ways to solve this
problem of translocating protons into
the intermembrane space let's look at
panel a of storyboard 14 at the upper
left we see coenzyme q in its quinone
form in this form it's at exid ìiím dye
own it's one of our cofactors and we've
also referred to in the past as a mobile
electron carrier in that regard it falls
into the same grouping of molecules such
as the NAD+ NADH pair the squiggly line
at the lower right corner of the quinone
molecule depicts isoprene units actually
there's a series of about six to ten of
these isoprenes
in the Q molecule these probably
facilitate association with hydrophobic
regions such as regions in membranes the
structure of coenzyme q allows it to
pick up electrons one at a time from an
electron donor
deliver them one at a time to a place
where the electrons are going to go that
is an electron recipient this panel
shows the step by step mechanism by
which electrons one at a time can reduce
the oxidized form of coenzyme q called q
here or the quinone - it's fully reduced
form Q H - also known as the
hydroquinone these electrons come from
complex one or complex two or another
membrane bound entry point for electrons
into respiration the first electron
converts the quinone Q to the semi
quinone radical the semi quinone will
then pick up another proton and electron
to form the fully reduced species the
hydroquinone or qh - the hydroquinone qh
- is fully loaded with electrons the
fully reduced hydroquinone will next
deliver its two electrons to complex
three the technical name of complex 3 is
coenzyme q cytochrome c oxidase
reductase this net name gives a hint
that the electrons are going to pass
from coenzyme q in its reduced form to
an oxidized form of cytochrome c which
is also non-covalently associated with
complex 3 let's look at panel B a single
molecule of Q H to the hydroquinone
contains two electrons that are going to
be transferred to complex three one
electron is going to reduce iron 3 to
iron 2 in a first molecule of cytochrome
C and then the second electron is going
to be used to reduce a second molecule
of cytochrome C it's convenient to break
this overall reaction scheme into two
parts I'll call them cycle one in cycle
two in cycle one the first molecule of
cytochrome C is going to be reduced and
then in cycle two the second molecule
will be reduced i've further broken down
the cycle into eight steps at the upper
left of complex 3 you'll see a site that
are marked with an X this is an iron
sulfur protein this is going to be the
docking site for qh2 the semi quinone
sometimes it is called the Q Delta site
the reduced quinone qh2 gives up two
protons and one electron to form the
semi quinone radical q -
the electron in step three goes over to
reduce ferric ion to ferrous ion that is
iron three to iron two in cytochrome C
as I mentioned earlier cytochrome C is
another one of our mobile electron
carriers it's going to float away and go
off to complex 4 at this point in step
four B the semi quinone radical is going
to give up its second electron to
cytochrome B L which it can which is a
constituent of the complex 3 from the
standpoint of coenzyme q at this point
it's lost both of its electrons it has
been converted to the fully oxidized
form Q as depicted in step four a the
electron at cytochrome B L flows into
cytochrome B H and from there it will
subsequently flow into a molecule of the
parental dye quinone Q the one electron
reduction of the dye quinone Q results
in the formation of the semi quinone
radical once again this is at position Y
the way I've drawn the complex 3 in
panel B position Y is also called the qi
site at this point the semi quinone
radical will just stay where it is for a
few minutes we'll pick it up again in
the second half of the Q cycle to
summarize what happened in the first
half of the Q cycle two protons have
been translocated from the matrix into
the intermembrane space and one electron
has been transferred to cytochrome c
which then translocates across the outer
surface of the mitochondrial inner
membrane to complex for at this point
please look at panel C now we're going
to take a look at the second half of the
Q cycle at the bottom of complex 3 in
step one you'll see the orphaned semi
quinone radical that we just created
keep in mind that we are going to come
back and use that radical in a couple of
minutes so bear with me at step two we
see a second molecule of the
hydroquinone qh2 inside the
mitochondrial inner membrane we're going
to borrow this molecule for a short time
and then we're going to restore it so
this Q h2 is essentially catalytic in
the overall reaction scheme in step
three we see that this bar
rohde molecule of the hydroquinone qh2
gives up two protons in one electron
just as we had seen in the first half of
the cycle you will note that we are
reducing a second molecule of cytochrome
C which is then going to go off to
complex 4 we're also going to be
producing a second molecule of coenzyme
q the fully oxidized form of the
cofactor in step four B the semi quinone
radical just as happened in cycle 1 will
give up the electron to cytochrome B L
the electron will then go to cytochrome
B H and then will flow into the semi
quinone radical that we had left over
from the first cycle this radical exists
at site Y or as I called it before the
Qi site of complex 3 the reduction of
the semi quinone radical at step 6 is
concomitant in step 7 with the
acquisition of 2 protons from the matrix
the series of reactions ultimately
result in restoration of Q H to the semi
quinone in the mitochondrial inner
membrane at this point we have restored
the molecule of qh to its Deb 8 that we
had borrowed initially at step 2
the second cycle has also produced net Q
the oxidized form of the cofactor which
is now free to go on to complexes 1 & 2
and to pick up more reducing equivalents
just looking at the second half of the Q
cycle what we see is that we've
translocated another 2 protons into the
intermembrane space and we have
transferred a second electron to
cytochrome C so cycle 1 and cycle 2 each
result in the translocation of 2 protons
from the matrix to the intermembrane
space and each results in the transfer
of one electron to cytochrome C looking
at the whole Q cycle that is cycle 1 in
cycle 2 together we get a pair of
electrons that enter from Q H to 4
protons are translocated into the
intermembrane space and to reduced
molecules of cytochrome C which then
migrate to complex 4 where they'll be
later oxidized let's turn to storyboard
15 and panel a in panel a
another way to look at the cue cycle
I'll emphasize that this is not as
chemically accurate as the two-step
process that I showed you previously and
I'm not going to discuss it here further
nevertheless I think that this
presentation makes it relatively easy
for you to see the overall stoichiometry
of the cue cycle
let's now turn to storyboard 15 panel B
in the way of a high-level review of
electron transport so far electrons from
nutrient oxidation have been deposited
into the electron transport chain the
transfer of electrons to oxygen resulted
in energy that is used to power pumps
pumps that pump protons into the
intermembrane space we've looked at the
Q cycle as one example of several of how
protons are pumped it took energy to
create this proton gradient when we
release the proton gradient by allowing
the protons to flow through the ATP
synthase we're going to be able to use
that energy in order to accomplish the
otherwise energetically uphill
phosphorylation of ADP into ATP now
let's look at storyboard 15 panel see
this panel shows the F naught F 1 proton
translocating ATP synthase also known as
the ATP synthase to put things in
perspective at the top is the
intermembrane space
which is where the protons have been
translocated in the middle is the
mitochondrial inner membrane and at the
bottom is the mitochondrial matrix
because we're prompt with pumped protons
into the intermembrane space its pH is
about three-quarters of a pH unit lower
than the pH of the matrix of the
mitochondrion proton flow is going to be
regulated in response to physiologic
needs I'll talk about that regulation
and how it occurs later for now however
let's look at protons flowing through
the F naught F 1 complex
let's imagine that the broken line
indicates a channel through which
protons will flow other structural
features include a shaft which I have
indicated as gamma and a ring in which
the shaft is embedded which I've
indicated as the C ring when protons
flow both the shaft and the C
we'll move as you'll see in a clockwise
rotation at the bottom of the overall
apparatus our three alpha and three beta
subunits these are not going to rotate
that is they're going to say fixed in
position while the C ring in the gamma
subunit rotate the beta subunit contains
a site X which is going to be the active
site for conversion of ADP plus
inorganic phosphate to ATP I've drawn a
little elbow on the bottom of the gamma
subunit let's imagine that protons are
flowing and the flow makes that subunit
spin around and further imagine that the
elbow is bumping into the active sites
that is the X sites there are three of
the X sites one on each of the B
subunits at the bottom of the overall
apparatus imagine that the energy
involved is translocated from the elbow
to the active sites and that's what's
going to help us align adp and pi2 make
the overall chemical reaction favorable
that is a hypothetical but not for our
fetched way to think about the way that
ATP is made let's now look at panel D
the current view is that the active site
oscillates among three different
confirmations during the time the
protons are translocated these three
conformational States are referred to as
Oh for open l for loose and T for tight
in the open state nothing is present at
the active site X the conversion of open
Toulouse is concomitant with the binding
of ADP in inorganic phosphate as protons
continue to flow the loose site is
converted into the tight state the
energy associated with this
conformational change results in the
alignment of the inorganic phosphate
such that the conditions are now
favorable for it to phosphorylate adp
and form ATP further proton flow results
in the tight state being converted to
the open state which ejects the formed
ATP out into the mitochondrial matrix so
at each cycle of open to loose to tight
a molecule of ATP is made and then it is
ejected this goes on again and again and
again that's the overall mechanism by
which ATP is synthesized
at the high level proton flow results in
the movement as the turning of a rotor
it is a lot like a waterwheel that might
drive the rotation of a millstone that
grinds grain into flour the rotation of
the shaft provides energy to bump into
the X sites resulting in the conversion
of a first sub unit to the open
conformation another sub unit to the
loose state and a third sub unit to
tight then the process starts over again
with each cycle producing one molecule
of ATP as one final point a point that
explains how this process is regulated
proton flow results from the binding of
ADP that is ADP this will become
important in a few minutes when we talk
about how the whole system is regulated
now let's look at story board 16 let's
look at all four panels panels A through
D in the last part of this lecture I'd
like to talk about how respiration is
coupled to the TCA cycle and glycolysis
this is really the first time in 507
that we're going to see the beauty of
coordinated pathway regulation I'm going
to use a physiological scenario in order
hopefully to make it all make sense in
this scenario
imagine that you're being chased down
the street by a dog in order to start
running away from the dog we're going to
need some ATP that's very quickly
generated from glucose by glycolysis the
TCA cycle is also going to be operative
along with the pathway we haven't seen
so far fatty acid oxidation in both
cases the TCA cycle and fatty acid
oxidation reduced electron carriers are
going to be produced that are going to
give up their electrons to the electron
transport chain ultimately to reduce
oxygen to water and with concomitant
pumping of protons into the
intermembrane space resulting in the
lowering of the pH that is acidification
of the intermembrane space as I
mentioned earlier that flow of protons
through the AP synthase is triggered by
the binding of adp to the X site on the
beta subunit of the enzyme complex as
your muscles are working hard and you're
running away from the dot the
concentration of adp in the
mitochondrial matrix is going to be
increasing thus proton
flow is going to be initiated as you run
more and more the protons are depleted
from the intermembrane space
it's not known exactly how this
reduction in proton concentration
results in accelerated movement of
electrons through the electron transport
chain it's tempting to speculate there
one or more of the redox centers within
the electron transfer chain may be pH
sensitive let's imagine that that is the
case so let's imagine that the raising
of pH that is the decrease in hydrogen
ion concentration in the intermembrane
space results in the facilitated flow of
electrons from complex 1 or complex 2 to
oxygen next let's look to the far left
at the bottom of panel D as you draw
more electrons into respiration NADH is
going to be converted to nad Plus it's
important now to remember that NADH
feedback inhibits any step at which it's
produced in the TCA cycle thus as you're
running away from the dog the NADH
concentration drops and that means that
there's going to be less inhibition of
the steps at which NADH is produced in
the TCA cycle thus looking at the big
picture the binding of increased
concentrations of ADP to the ATP
synthase over on the far right results
in the activation of the TCA cycle and
other metabolic pathways that will
result in the delivery of more electrons
to the electron transport chain in order
to allow you to continue to run away
from the dog next let's imagine that
you've been running for quite a while
and let's look at complex 4 where oxygen
is bound sooner or later you're going to
be becoming oxygen limited you're going
to be panting heavily this means that
electron flow from a reduced electron
carriers to oxygen is going to slow down
as we become more hypoxic respiration
starts to fail but hypoxia dramatically
increases the levels or activities of
the enzymes of glycolysis thus
glycolysis will switch over to becoming
our principal ATP generation machine as
we increase the rate of glycolysis the
flex goes from glucose to pyruvate but
the pyruvate can't be oxidized because
it can't enter respiration because we
don't have enough oxygen present in
order to oxidize it so what happens is
we activate lactate dehydrogenase to
convert pyruvate to lactate conversion
of pyruvate to lactate has two
consequences the first is the conversion
results in the conversion of NADH to
NAD+ remember that this is the lactate
shuttle and that nad plus is now
available to allow glyceraldehyde
3-phosphate dehydrogenase to continue
processing molecules of glucose into ATP
a second consequence of activation of
lactate dehydrogenase is the fact that
lactate spills out into the blood where
it acidifies the blood the pH drops now
let's think about what the consequences
are when the pH of the blood drops I
want you to think back to the lectures
in which Joann talked about
cooperativity the Bohr effect and the
affinity of oxygen for hemoglobin Joann
told us that protons are heterotrophic
allosteric effectors that effectively
loosen the affinity of oxygen for
hemoglobin so as you're running away
from the dog glycolysis becomes the main
pathway you produce a lot of lactate
that goes into the blood the pH drops
oxygen lowers its affinity for
hemoglobin and thus becomes more
available for the pathway of respiration
oxygen is now back in the system and
binds to complex four so you kind of get
what we could call a second wind that
allows you to continue using respiration
to run away from the dog in other words
you've adapted to the stressful state
and are now able to continue running now
let's put it all together a dog starts
chasing you
you're readily available energy reserves
and free glucose as well as glycogen
reproduce rapid ATP that will get you
moving away from the dog additionally
respiration will be contributing lots of
ATP to allow you escape the dog and as
you're running ADP concentrations will
go up inside your mitochondria that will
basically release the proton gradient
allow
the ATP synthase to work very quickly
and very hard to make a lot more ATP
nadh concentrations in the mitochondria
will drop with physical activities this
helps boot up the dehydrogenases of the
TCA cycle they become less inhibited
your TCA cycle will accelerate in order
to produce more reducing equivalents to
power the electron transport chain
all of this will continue until your
oxygen becomes limiting then respiration
starts to fail but the hypoxic state
turns up the activities of the enzymes
of glycolysis thus glycolysis
accelerates and helps accommodate but
pyruvate at the end of glycolysis cannot
be further oxidized because there's not
enough oxygen it has to be converted to
lactate the lactate acidifies the blood
the Bohr effect causes the release of
more oxygen into the blood making it
more available to complex 4 in order to
reboot the electron transport chain
overall this is a marvelously regulated
physiological system that seems to have
evolved in order to promote our survival